I was the dentist on Seinfeld Cheryl
would you ready the nitrous oxide please
so we rehearsed that and then they left
and I stayed on my set I was rehearsing
when nobody else was on the set but me
and I Heard a Voice say Hey you know it
would be funny
what
and I looked around and up on a ladder
and there's an electrician yeah I go uh
What uh man on the ladder what would be
funny he's on a lot what what would be
funny he goes to be funny if before you
gave it to Jerry you take a hit yourself
first and I said oh my God that is funny
so I did
and Jerry Falls over that's awesome and
cracks up they were telling me hey great
joke that's a great bit I go and I said
he gave it to me all heads turned toward
the electrician in the corner he just
goes
where a great idea is going to come
right right right right